Vous avez certainement vu
ces vidéos
des lycéens et professeurs du lycée de Sevran
en seine-saint-nil
valent tous les discours.
Ces vidéos ont été vues des 1.000.000 de fois.
En fait, c'est 1 image fidèle de l'école
qui partout manque de professeurs, d'aush,
de personnels médicaux, sociaux.
La seine-saint-nic,
département parmi les plus pauvres, en est 1 expression
concentrée, 1 enfant y perd en moyenne 18 mois de cours
sur l'ensemble de sa scolarité.
Et comme partout
les revendications depuis des années restent l'être
morte.
Alors les personnels ont pris les affaires en main,
établis les besoins.
Ils ont dit, pas de moyens, pas de rentrer
le 26/02, jour de la rentrée.
La grève était massive dans le 93.
Depuis le mouvement est recondu,
le soutien des parents est impressionnant,
les personnels, leurs syndicats sont soudés,
ils veulent 1 plan d'urgence.
Rien qu'en sainte-sanie, il faudrait notamment
5000 enseignants,
deux-mille-deux-cents ush supplémentaires.
Le coût de ce plan
15 fois moins que le coût cumulé du
essaynue et de l'uniforme à l'école
dont quasiment personne à part vous ne veut.
Et les personnels
refusent votre choc
contre le savoir et les groupes de niveaux qui,
après parcoursupent
la mise en cause du bac et du lycée
professionnel,
sont 1 mesure
supplémentaire de tri social et de sélection
dans le 93, ils savent qui va en faire les frais,
madame la ministre,
la grève des professeurs du 93
traduite 1 mouvement de fond
et elle a 1 portée nationale,
elle fait partout.
L'objet d'une profonde sympathie
parce que les problèmes et les besoins qu'elle pose
sont posés partout.
Craignez qu'elle ne soit contagieuse.
À Paris, par exemple,
les représentants de parents
de 67 collèges veulent être reçus par le recteur
contre les groupes de niveaux.
Alors, madame la ministre,
quand comptez-vous vraiment renoncer
au choc des savoirs et au groupe de niveau ?
Quand comptez-vous faire droit au plan d'urgence
exigé par les personnels du 93 ?
Et comment comptez-vous faire
alors que votre
gouvernement vient d'annoncer près de 700.000.000
de coupes supplémentaires dans le budget de l'école ?